[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from 14 nations converge in st.
Louis as US chess champs calm presents
the third annual spring chess classic
indeed it is the third annual spring
chess classic welcome back to st. Louis
in Studio B for round 7 coverage hello
my name is Ben Simon and I'm joined by
Grandmaster Amnon Hambleton Aman how are
you feeling today I'm feeling great Ben
I am excited to get in another day of
commentary with one and only Ben Simon
thank you very much I'll do my best to
live up to your standard of expectations
now our expectations yesterday included
dealing with a field of six players tied
for first in Group A no longer at least
right now let's take a look at our
standings in our masters group because
yesterday we had all of the leaders
playing each other three big games but
only one of them ended decisively it was
Geoffrey Zhang / Liam Lee and now
because of that going into today
Geoffrey Zhang is in clear first ya know
Geoffrey is he's the new player to watch
he's right on top of the table he broke
free from that six player group and a
very impressive victory it seems
actually that we can now say that look
Wang I mean he's having a reasonably bad
tournament he's taking some losses
actually lost to Hansen and he lost to
to Zhang here so he's really gonna have
to recover as you see look Wang LAN
right there in the middle of the table
and you know you don't expect him to
stay there very long as he needs to make
a big surge towards the top if he wants
to finish well it's definitely still
possible you know three rounds to go yes
thing is going until Sunday so still
time to turn the ship still time to
write it okay
our B group is a similar story we have a
clear leader but he's been clear leader
for a little bit longer by genchi from
China is now at five points still he had
a point in half lead at one point yeah
but now he's bars pullets has shortened
that to just one and actually bars
pullets is already out of
Tournament Hall today with a draw right
yeah so he he's inching closer he'll be
at four and a half and by ginchy again
he's he's still got some tough players
left to play
but it's the chasing pack that's more
interesting because we have bars pullets
who's making that surge we have Sorokin
who's actually been on a tremendous run
since that Oh to start that we remember
so he he and Alexander Mesa are right
behind so I don't feel like by gin she
thinks that the tournaments all wrapped
up or anything like you mentioned a one
loss and all of a sudden he might not
even be in first place anymore indeed
more and more chess to play and speaking
of that let's take a look at our
schedule now the games start every day
at 1:00 p.m. Central time but we are on
the air with you two and a half hours
later at 3:30 p.m. Central time we have
two more days of play after today we're
going to finish it up on Sunday evening
our pardon me Wednesday March there are
those dates right I don't think those
dates Sunday March 10th Sunday March
10th I was right the first time or for
Regulus is gonna be our final date has
it been that the whole time man I feel
like I'm being printed anyway i anyway i
shows how much i look at things in
detail 11:00 a.m. we're going to be
starting early on sunday march 10th and
if there is a play-off necessary for
first place we're gonna have it the same
day at 5:00 p.m. that's why we're
starting early and also sunday is
daylight saving time right we're gonna
be jumping ahead anyway so it's gonna
feel like three hours early that's gonna
man I am NOT looking forward to that
no now we encourage you to join us
online for this big event us chess
champs calm is where you want to go to
watch this have the YouTube chat open in
a separate window and keep interacting
with us because us chess champs calm
really cool experience you're gonna see
the games happening on the digital board
and you'll be able to follow whatever
you want doesn't it necessarily have to
be with us at the same time I want to
check in with our chat they're pretty
active already as you
no life or name says yay time for some
chess he has a really uplifting name I
have to say that's a good one
hello viola player nice to see you again
and yeah it took so long by jean-paul
Roman yeah
we are back so thanks for joining us
okay so let's glance at our pairings in
group a this is what's happening right
now just two floors up Benjamin Bach
versus Rustom chasm Jean up has already
ended in a draw the other four games are
in progress Aria and tari versus Vasily
about Terry and Yvonne Chaka also just
true just now just before the broadcast
yeah okay well that game is over as well
thank you Eric Hansen versus alien is
Nick Liam Lee versus Ray Robson and our
key matchup hey we have two favorites
they both feel like locals but only one
is and the other is our leader it's
Murugan Akopian versus Geoffrey Zhang so
what's happening in this game so far a
month well Geoffrey Zhang here he's
playing with the black pieces and he's
got a little bit of a cushion now he
doesn't need to win these games I think
he'll take his chances but I don't think
he's going all out but it's funny as I
say that after remember we're talking
about Geoffrey Zhang and I have the
feeling that he almost just loves to
play chess I he was playing Hansen at a
previous round and he declined what is a
pretty known repetition and I think
played even a subpar move just to keep
playing so I get this feeling like he's
always trying to play a few moves ago I
got that same impression as I mean this
positions kind of wrapping up but you
know he throws in that movie III wants
to compromise the structure and while
this does look like it is heading
towards a draw between c5 has been
played I mean he's just looking to to
create something maybe maybe he's trying
to use his time advantage maybe he's
trying to use the exposed White King but
the players are still playing this
position we're on move 31 I don't think
either players too concerned about this
but you know long term you have to be
quite careful about this pawn running up
the board but I think it's about
balanced by the fact that White's King
is really exposed and that can often be
huge problems in
position like this so if black finds
time to sort of let's say an idea like
rook here to maybe stop the Queen trade
and if I just get that that free time
for an escape square all of a sudden
those two pieces can you know come down
to the second rank and totally switch
their attention so might be some you
know outside chances for for either side
here's why it has that pass pawn but the
exposed King but I think this is this is
very equal here and it wouldn't be
surprised if Kobe and Zhang had a draw
in in this game right now in your
opinion stopping the Queen trade is
paramount at this point for Geoffrey
right yeah not so much in the sense that
you know if the Queen's are off that
we're losing or anything like that but
if he wants to play for for anything
he's probably got to go here if he plays
a move like modern rook rook here for
example then after queen c8 the Queen's
are gonna get traded and you know it's I
can't even take it so I I sort of have
to play Queen FA it's just not not a
very comfortable way to deal with things
and okay maybe this pawn gets pushed and
there may be other moves but let's just
say an end game like this sometimes you
have to be quite careful with this pawn
because if you spend time going over to
take it then maybe this King somehow
reaches your King side pawns first so
some sort of scenario like this and
although black actually wins the pawn
it's White's King who maybe gets in
there and you have to be quite careful
here playing black even though you're up
upon so these are just obviously some
sort of far out nightmare scenarios that
can happen but would that be a definite
win for white in that situation or could
black draw that this draw this one might
be close but probably I mean if white
can take the pawns it's definitely wind
the reason that it might be draw though
is if black can arrange to play f4 and
get rid of one pawn and then often with
the outside H pawn you can draw that
position so but this would be Geoffrey
you know allowing absolutely everything
wrong to happen so that's why I think
maybe just keeping the Queen's on is
easier and we can do that by bringing
the rook all the way back to EA
but the if the b-pawn poses any problems
is gonna be something like this where
you get an outside pond try to use it as
a decoy but if white gets into any
trouble it's gonna be a result of this
king position on g1 so both players kind
of have their things they're fighting
for here and this team will definitely
continue a little bit but I have to say
it does look very even right now the
players are no strangers to each other
especially in this setting
Jeffrey and Akopian have played five
times before at least in classical chess
probably more if you include Blitzen
rapid but Jeffrey has never beaten var
var beat him twice and then they had
three draws and they've all occurred
here in st. Louis and either a u.s.
championship mom or one of the seasonal
classics the classic series started in
2017 right and the US Championships I
think the first year Jeffrey played was
16 and ever since then they've been
unintentional rivals but let's see if
let's see if Jeffrey can get his maybe
its first victory today although it's
looking kind of even yeah let's jump
over to Group B these are the games
happening right now two floors up and at
US chess champs calm now unless I'm
outdated again there's only one game
over right now in this field and it's
the one right there in the middle
Sorokin and baarish pullets saw them
upstairs doing a post-mortem that was a
draw but the games in progress
Sergei Ehrenburg versus he had in Stein
Grimson Nicolas theodoro vs. Gregory
katana Denis CAD rich versus Christian
korilla and our key matchup these are
becoming a little easy to pick you gotta
follow the leader Alexander Mistah
versus by ginchy it's polling versus
China okay let's see this game yeah this
is not just the leaders game but this is
actually the two highest rated players
in the B group this is Alexander Mistah
at twenty five ninety-two and by ginchy
twenty five ninety three so but an E low
point between them although in the
tournament there is a point and a half
in the standings by ginchy currently
sitting on five points and hasn't lost a
game and as I keep saying hasn't looked
on
comfortable and that's that that's just
the biggest plus for a chess player if
you can get those consistent games where
you might not win every game but you're
drawing effortlessly I mean that that's
the type of consistency your rating is
always gonna go up by winning and
drawing you know unless you're playing
some really low rated players but
generally that's that's the recipe
consistency is key and bhaijan she is
showing that in this tournament right
here we see him in position I want to
back up a little bit because we can sort
of show how we got here the game started
off as a petrov but what I want to focus
on is right here was was sort of
interesting when white played this move
Bishop takes e5 with the idea Queen a5
so right here things are basically
liquidating it does look very equal I'm
sure the evaluation would suggest that
you can't often change that when you're
dealing with a petrov i need to get rid
of the knight on e5 to save the pawn on
c4 right right you need to you don't
need necessarily get rid of it but you
need to deal with c4 so getting rid of
it is one of those ways I could defend
the pawn as well but I don't really want
to have double pawns in front of my king
so yeah actually after an 85 he decided
okay I'm gonna take with the bishop and
then play this move Queen a5 with the
idea that this pawn right here is
actually kind of difficult to defend a
six might be played but you know maybe I
get the move c5 in it's unclear why it's
he's pressing in the middle right he
sees these pawns are dangerous and what
bhaijan she decided to do here I thought
was very instructive and exactly the way
you're supposed to treat these positions
he played them of Bishop d6 and the idea
and this could be inverted as well I
mean we could play b6 here as black and
then after they take the pawn I can
bring the bishop back so similar idea
but getting the bishop out of the way
first and the idea being okay if I play
C 5 there's actually b6 here and you
don't take my bishops I'm taking your
queen and if you take here well then you
just sort of covered your pawns for
nothing and there's nothing for you to
take on a7 that was the whole point of
this so usually you go grab that pawn
that's exactly how the game went Meester
took the pawn on a7 and then you see
this move be set
you might be wondering you know what
what's happening here why is this so
good why just grabbed a pond for free on
a 7 but if you look at the position
you'll see that all these ponds are
completely stopped by blacks Bishop and
pawns a really nice outpost on c5 or
that Bishop can put a lot of pressure on
the King and if you look at this Queens
position the Queen and Bishop together
with this pond on b6 actually take away
all the Queen's retreat squares so it's
not that easy for me to get back into
the action we've discussed a few games
especially yesterday been where the
Queen was so offside and that actually
cost two of the strongest players in the
tournament there their games positions
like this make me really nervous because
it looks like I know the Queen is gonna
have a couple moves to get out of the
corner but can the Queen be trapped here
right probably not okay
probably not trapped because you always
have these these footholds here that I
can play Queen here and there or I can
play Queen here and there so I can
always get my Queen out we're not
concerned about that but again just like
we've seen before it's not so much about
trapping that Queen just about it being
offside it's just not near the action
and what black is doing is controlling
the only open file and using his strong
bishop against the knight Bishop c5 or
Bishop d6 it's really hard for for white
to make an escape square for the King
because h3 that doesn't help at all and
g3 well you might invite my queen in so
it's really hard for white to free the
King to deal with the open file strong
bishop and we got that Queen way out of
play so it continued Queen a6 I mean
he's got to get out of there
Bishop c5 taking control that nice
diagonal and I mean white just has to
trade the rook why I mean rookie - it's
such a huge threat hating this pawn once
the Queen joins the action we see that
blacks basically on a power play here
three-on-two that Queen on a6 is not
helping rook e1 and now black makes an
escape square so that there's no
checkmate for him to worry about and
once this happens I think black is
really in the driver's seat again we
have to stop this move Queen e2 look at
that Queen it can't jump back here or
here nowhere can't get back to help so
White's got to use this King stop Queen
e2 but we see the Queen finally invade
now in doing so it does give up control
this square but you'll see with a forced
series of checks
he actually takes a pawn so now the
pawns are back to even but we have that
innate advantage here for by June she
the the Queen on a for finally rejoins
the action on e2 but basically you see
two pawns here holding back three and
the potential for a passed pawn later in
the endgame here for black as well as
you know what is this guy doing on d3 so
white has a lot - a lot to prove in in
this position we just saw the move 94 h5
93 on the board this is the current
position here as a once again I have to
say by June she is is four choice this
started off as just a petrov you can
tell he's not out here trying to you
know behead people he's playing very
very reasonable controlled chess and
when his opponents give him chances or
they invite complications
I mean he's ready for them and he's
always shown that he can handle those
types of complications calculations
whatever it may be he's up on the clock
I mean we've never seen him in time
pressure of this tournament and right
now he's sitting and what I would call
very comfortable position I think good
chances to win this game as we've seen
him win games from positions that were a
lot more equal than this yeah by June
she I don't know if that we talked about
it too much he's only 19 years old and
he won last year's North American Open
which is a big tournament I mean if you
get us chesses chess life in the mail
you'll see advertisers for the North
American open all the time right so by
chance she may be a name that we'll have
to remember around here a little bit
more yeah it's definitely picking up
some some ello from this tournament if
it continues to go this way which I
believe will probably shoot him over
26-hundred don't know if he's been there
before but sure he has
let's glance at what the players are
competing for in this event there's a
$22,000 prize fund in Group A and the
winners walk away with six thousand four
thousand three thousand and it goes on
down no one is going home empty-handed
but more is better
Group B 14 thousand dollar prize fund
and the champion leaves with 4 grand
okay so now that we've got our
introductions out of the way let's look
at the rest of the games
anything in Group A catch your eye at
Eric Hanson's game perhaps yeah we can
look at this game Eric is playing an
alien is Nick in the egg group and this
game does look like we might see
something happen now it might not look
that bad it might actually look like
maybe it's pretty pretty even especially
on material but I think it's important
to note a few things about the position
number one the time situation we see
that that classic 30-minute time
advantage and it's going to be an index
favor here ten moves to make so
definitely not unreasonable to think
that Hansen will be just fine handling
this time pressure but I think it's
important to note just on the subject of
time pressure that players often have
this idea that like Oh for example
Grisha Alexander Grisha it's like oh
he's he's better in time pressure you
know you see so good when the clock is
low he should just wait until the clock
gets down there and play the whole game
like that he's like there's some science
against that right and logically you
know there's a lot of players who are
extremely good in time pressure but
there's no one in the world who could
say that they're better in time pressure
then not in time pressure they might be
better than their opponent and then you
might see a gap when it gets the time
pressure but every chess player is going
to prefer having time on the clock you
know think about everything calculate
everything so mistakes will happen in
time pressure and yeah Erik's in a tough
position here where it looks like blacks
position is just so easy to play it's
dead even on material but I think that
Nick has a noticeable advantage here
strong knight on d5 way more active King
the thing is black can activate his King
pretty easily white on the other hand
really has to work to to get this King
out and also once you get in the middle
of the board it might not be safe there
even some checks but blacks is really
really well placed the bishop isn't
doing anything for the moment but we if
we update the board we see the last
couple moves there Knight e3 f5 and it's
clear that that Bishop can join on one
of two very useful diagonals either
hitting that pawn in the center of the
board
or Bishop h6 pressuring those two
knights and kind of
Mining whites positions so I think that
Hanson is at risk of losing this game
pretty seriously just based on the how
easy it is for black to play and whether
or not he can find accurate moves up
until time control now if he hits time
control you might be a totally different
story altogether as the position is
probably not that bad but you know he
needs to simplify he needs to simplify
pieces and it is not an easy task here
now I might be overstating things a
little bit but I really do prefer blacks
position and we'll see if he can can
hold this because he's make more than 30
minutes on the clock and he has those
moves that are just kind of obvious to
play just has a few few moves in his in
his position that he might play rather
quickly so what would you do as News
Nick so a four is just been played so
it's Ilyas turn I think the the first
couple things to note Hanson but would
you would you like a four I like a four
a five is an idea probably not one I
just so they want to do but the reason
that I like a four is because if I ever
put a knight on c4 I can't really be
kicked out anymore so I might put a
knight there and then threaten the idea
of Knight takes Knight and you know then
this poem v6 starts to hang so this is
one idea we might see the bishop come to
d8 maybe even just to deal with that
momentarily we might see the exchange of
knights followed by black putting his
King on d5 but I like the move a four it
definitely seems seems correct here so
Eric's gonna be looking for forced ways
to trade things right like he's looking
at stuff like ninety four and you know
any sort of force calculation where I
get liquidation he wants to get those if
you could trade the a pawn for the
b-pawn for Eric that would be great and
vice versa for Nanak he wants to leave
pawns leave pieces on the board if he
can try to create more areas more more
space for Eric to to blender here as a
result of time pressure it's worth
noting that last night while it wasn't
on the official tournament schedule
there was a big gala in st. Louis well
closer to the river but still in Saint
Louis City right
I don't know how many players in the
field were there but I know you were
there and I know erica was there and
there was some blitz Simon's going on
yeah well I don't I
she wasn't aware of this event but what
Ben's referring is there was a gala last
night
oh so you didn't go I know there was a
gala but just not aware of the gala that
that was happening but there there was a
therapist a gala last night and it was a
really fun event it was a fundraiser and
I thought it was great as one of the
first ones that I went to since I've
been here in Eric Hanson among a lot of
other participants including Fabiana
Cara Juana was also at the event and
they were doing so I had the kids on the
stage and I think Hanson and few other
GM's Fabiano included did like a five
board Simon with clocks so they were
they were jumping around they had to day
to make sure not to lose on time Eric
won all five of his games
I think Fabiano may or may not have
suffered some losses no man that's you
had to be there you had to be there well
it was a it was a fundraiser for
Ascension Health's your move chess which
is putting scholastic chess this program
specifically in the Ferguson flourescent
district which is very near and dear to
the chest club's heart so you know
there's chess all over the st. Louis
area but this was specifically for them
to serve them well and I know that Frank
were gone our Nick were going rather
pardon me Nick we're going is heading up
the program as part of ascension he's
been on these shows many times if you
look back on a youtube channel you'll
see plenty of pieces with him and
actually he's a he's a big chess player
too so I know he is and he legitimately
he is really into chess and I could tell
when when I met him he was he was
thrilled to just have everyone there and
I don't think he could say it enough
over the night he was just thanking
everyone so you could tell he's really
passionate yeah good stuff good stuff
okay Group B for B let's go to surrogate
ehrenburg's game against Stein Crimson
USA a former US Championship competitor
against Iceland we're seeing Stein
Grim's in here in the st. Louis for the
first time right and what is going on
here this one you can tell already just
from from the
pieces on the board is a much different
game than some of the ones we've taken a
look at we are nowhere close to the
endgame here and the pieces are gonna be
flying I want to jump back into the
middle game and just see how we got here
but it seems like there
I mean Arenberg produces games that
usually end in results okay he's been
playing some in my opinion some very
eccentric very fun chess I just want to
tell you late-breaking just now theodoro
and katana have drawn their game haha so
so let's let's take a look at this so
Aaron Berg is it looks like they had an
option to repeat here that was what took
a few moves in the middle of the games
with King h8 was played by Stein Grimson
and after Bishop b3 Bishop e6 we had
repetition and then Ehrenburg decided
I'm gonna play on maybe that was for a
number of reasons maybe he just enjoyed
his position maybe he likes to play
chess I can't disagree with that sort of
the same mentality as Geoffrey you know
just why take the repetition when when
there are other ways to sort of maintain
the flexible position and Bishop c4 was
chosen it seems like a very good one a
six is being targeted
maybe the reason that he didn't want to
go for it or was hesitant at first with
the repetition was maybe the
continuation we saw in the game Knight
f4 played and hey you're gonna get that
pawn on a six but in exchange you get to
take that pawn on d3 so we saw the d3
pawn being exchanged for the pawn on e6
if white ever has to play a move like
this this is basically something you
would always say is in favor of black
because of the light squares this Bishop
is not very strong and this guy right
here reigns supreme
on all these these weak light squares
and White's position really falls apart
without that light squared bishop or the
d3 pawn so he decides to go tactical and
play this move Bishop g5 with the idea
like okay you're gonna take one of my
bishops but I'd rather it be the dark
squared one I said that wasn't the
better Bishop so he's gonna give it up
voluntarily and try to take that Knight
back with the light squared bishop so
Bishop g5 played takes takes Bishop e7
defending this pawn on g5 which is all
of a sudden kind of thrown out there
from age six by force and now it's kind
of a target for white here so I think
we've just had one more move on the
board yes an IG 393 played and with 15
minutes ticking down Aaron bergsøe just
under 20 this one is is absolutely going
to be gonna be some fireworks here white
has ideas like Queen e2 with the idea
Queen efore hitting the knight
threatening checkmate in 1 also Queen e2
has the idea of bringing the rook over
to d1 which would be great makes that
Queen very uncomfortable sitting on d8
and on top of all this the other plusses
for white this pawn keeps the knight
completely out and this guy let's not
forget that is a passed pawn and I mean
if I'm not gonna make a queen at the
very least it's gonna be one of those
decoy pawns where I can push it up the
board there'll be threats that you
always have to consider about a7 hitting
the rook
a8 you got to leave a whole piece just
to watch that pawn make sure it doesn't
Queen and maybe that gives the upper
hand to white on the Kings side so
offhand I I have to say it looks like
Aaron Berg has achieved something here
over the last couple moves we see some
weak light squares here in blacks camp
although very solid and the move g6
can can always come into play you know
so you don't get mated on this diagonal
or queen coming to h5 right that's
always something to be scared about in
this position if I make a random move
here I get real scared of what about
this move Knight takes e5 and if Knight
takes for example just check me h7 and
h8 so we already have to watch out for
tactical ideas like this and no doubt
Arenberg just played the move Knight e4
to clear the way for for this dangerous
bishop to open up
I think Stein Grimson has a lot to worry
about in this position as I mentioned
you got way over in one side of the
board the a pawn and then way over on
the other you got checked me to worry
about so I like White's position here
and it seems as as Arenberg has just
moved got up from the board confidently
maybe he does as well and I think in the
hustle and bustle of our opening with
the schedule I neglected to mention what
these players are actually playing under
as far
time controls if you look at the clocks
you'll notice with every move they get a
30-second bonus added on right we were
looking at it so the we have the a and
the B round-robin fields 210 player
around Robins the time control 90
minutes for the first 40 moves after
they hit the 40th move they get 30
minutes added on the each clock for the
remainder of the game there is a
30-second increment for move number one
and also there's a 30 move draw rule in
effect we're not going to see any draws
except it before the 30th move the only
exception is if like there's a
three-fold repetition well okay then
that's forced and there actually was one
in one of the games that finished
earlier that's why it could finish
before move 30 as it was in fact a
repetition between a Sorokin and Darsh
bullets we might have gets a glance at
that a little bit later on but right now
I think the most newsworthy event in
group a our key matchup it's over it's a
draw a cobia and zhang have drawn their
game can we see how it happened them on
absolutely yeah no that always we were
paying attention to the key matchup in
group a between Jeffrey Zhang who is the
leader and it looks like things sort of
panned out as expected here Queeny 8 was
actually the choice of Jeffrey and
basically this beep on started rolling
up the board and what you get when the
b-pawn rolls up the board is black
pretty much has to he's compelled to do
something he has to react on the
kingside make some threats
if he doesn't that pawn is actually
gonna get really scary so in the end he
decided let's just trade off these rooks
and this is more or less a forced
repetition all right well Jeffrey found
a way out of that one it's another game
that's actually kind of similar to this
one in Group A is Liam Lee versus Ray
Robson right same material on the board
it's not over yet but it looks is this
very similar is this gonna be a draw
here this does look very similar the
pawn structure especially we have these
two pawns here for white and then the
three for black just like the last game
you go into games like this and the only
the way that someone can win is probably
with that a pawn
you could also over push with white Bush
that a pawn down too far you know all of
a sudden maybe you lose your King side
pawns but we're speaking about pretty
serious hypotheticals here because this
is this is going to be a draw I think
it's in this position it's actually
raise raise move and there's a few ways
to I mean the normal idea is is okay I
play rook here and your pawn is going
nowhere
so in order to free that pawn up you
have to play your King down to be one to
guard the pawn and then suddenly your
rook is free so it's like a two three
step process to even move the pun but
once you do that then your king and rook
are right next to the pond and you can
sort of you know move your rock up move
your King up move the pawn and slowly
inch forward like that but in the
meantime let's not forget how many moves
White has to expend just to accomplish
that black is no doubt going to be
pushing some pawns over here and getting
that King up into the action so these
games are I mean this is just completely
equal but I'll play it out I think
they'll play out a little bit you
probably want to see sort of what your
opponent's intending because black might
not even play broke a three right you
want to see how the players evaluate you
might think as white oh if my opponent
doesn't play rook a3 maybe he was a
little afraid of this plan and how
quickly my pawn gets going and vice
versa with black so I think the players
are probably just gonna demonstrate a
little bit their understanding and put
those pieces on the right squares but if
the players play as I expect I don't see
anything it would be crazy to have a
result other than a draw in this game so
I do expect look Wong and Ray Robson to
draw from this position here as most
rook in games are drawn and this one
especially that pawn a two is not even
going yet so I believe this one is
probably going to end in a draw well
this is a really important game for the
standings we've got number one seed
versus number three seed right here yes
also because of the Webster University
connection
these guys are no strangers to each
other actually Liam Lea's never defeated
ray Robson in a similar situation what
we looked at in a copious game Robson
has two victories over Liam Lee and
they've drawn three times and
has occurred between 2011 and 2016 so
they haven't played in a substantial
amount of time because well when
somebody leaves Webster you're not in
the clique anymore gonna be as close
Liam look long Liam has left the chat
right yeah so okay well we expect this
to be their lifetime draw number four
and how about Dennis CAD rich versus
Cristian korilla in Group B yeah I think
that's most of the action for Group A
because we we had that draw you know in
our critical matchup and then the
Kwong's position looks equal and Hanson
is still struggling so most of the
action which has been the case actually
again is in Group B it seems so let's
take a look at that position of gorilla
gorilla has also been been playing some
games that have been very attacking
always back and forth and once again we
find korilla in a position where both
sides are going for the throat it looks
like there's some holes in those castle
walls
there are especially right here and
right here there's something missing
this was a I believe it was a dragon so
no surprise that the game got so crazy
from that from the head position so
let's back up just a little bit because
we want to see how those holes developed
this was the the opening I think this
was the point here a five this move e5
by CAD Ridge was an inspired idea to you
know temporarily sacrifice upon and play
g5 and the idea is to put this Knight
out of commission he wants to say okay
that Knight goes back there i
centralized my knight and sort of
dominate the board positionally so
sometimes when you're attacking you have
to put your foot on the brake a little
bit and not necessarily just go for the
king all the time but it's nice to see a
little mix of positional and tactical
approach here 98 and 94 and Carillo says
okay you gave me a pond I'll give it
right back because I want the activity
as well for my Brooks for my bishops and
after long castle such an interesting
position there are two pieces hanging
now as a result of castling it's almost
like a tactic it's like how do you make
a double attack here
castle right your hey your kings hitting
the rook and the rook helps hit that
Bishop on d7 now well is there a way to
trap that rook on on b2 well you can
kind of played maybe Bishop b3 here
right and that would be more of a more
of a trap first of all if you want to
take that rook you're gonna have to work
hard because this bishop can always be
opened up to defend it and apart from
that I move like c4 can always free the
rook as well whether it's taking on c2
or taking bishop takes c4 rook takes c2
for example is already way off course
for white because you just can't keep
that bottled up in there if we could
then a move like Bishop e3 is actually
exactly what we want to do but castles
was played and here he didn't even have
to necessarily defend he plays the move
efore and he says okay if you if you
like Queen takes bishop here it's very
likely that move like Queen a5 getting
the Queen in here maybe threatening some
really interesting checkmate ideas for
example Queen takes Queen a5 now let me
just say that that white plays a bad
move plays pawn takes there would
already be some some checkmating ideas
like rook takes King takes Queen c3
check that's supported by the bishop
forced to go here and Queen B twos
already made so there are some ideas
there for korilla and that's why CAD
right here played the move Bishop takes
c5 because he realized once again he has
to combine attacked with defense he
can't just take that bishop and run away
with a full piece that's not these these
crazy positions work Bishop takes c5
Queen a5 and what was the point of
Bishop takes c5 he wants to deal with
this move by playing Bishop d4 and just
at all costs he had to get rid of this
guy Bishop on g7 was the strongest piece
on the board so he's going for a bishop
exchange he does achieve that drops the
Bishop to b3 and you get the feeling
that the way the game has developed here
and we'll just show the updated board
this korilla is a little bit low on time
so the moves are coming in fast
rook d2 was the last move played if you
do a body count here one extra pawn for
CAD rich on the C file and you also have
this pressure here of black never
wanting
to play Bishop takes b3 because if you
play that movie you kind of fix white
spawns you say okay you can take with
your a pawn all of a sudden those two
pawns connect much stronger that way
gives better shelter for the king queen
b7 was just played by gorilla he has the
idea to play a5 a4 I think this position
is is definitely better for for white
he's up that one pawn and he has
defensive ideas like rook over to c3
maybe move my king eventually and and
try to trade some pieces and I've got
good control a blacks King position so
there are some back rank mating ideas
later down the line I think that CAD
rich with a more than 10 minute time
advantage here somehow seems to have got
out of those complications in good shape
and I think that he has very good
chances to convert that one extra pawn
into into a win I think both of these
players at this point yeah are out of
contention for first prize right what
how do you I don't know how many closed
round robins you've played come off
played a few in st. Louis that's for
sure
okay well in that case whenever you are
in a situation like this where you're
out of contention for first is it hard
to find motivation for games down the
stretch well the answer is easier
probably for me than other players
because well I never win tournaments
been so I go in with very low
expectations and I meet them every time
but obviously if you're if you're
striving as everyone obviously should to
to win first place or to claim a big
prize and determine and you know
everyone's going home with something in
these tournaments but somebody's going
home with something more than someone
else and there's some pretty big prizes
to be won
one place in the standings can be as
much as $1,000 so these guys are
definitely fighting for that and when
you're when you know you're at a
contention for first place it definitely
hurts a little bit but I don't think
that I think it's almost more
invigorating to play spoiler at least
that's the opinion that I take you feel
like you have nothing to lose maybe your
chest actually improves because you
trust your instincts more and you just
go for it and maybe you've been a little
too tense to the whole tournament so
sometimes that can actually be very
liberating and
kind of a nice feeling to to just play
chess without without worrying about
where you're gonna place because you
feel like it's already far gone so maybe
maybe that's how these guys approach it
I think everyone's a little bit
different as as a competitor but that's
one way to look at it which you know
playing spoiler is always always fun you
don't want to be the guy who's just
getting picked on by everyone so that
starts happening too much you just start
loosening up and say alright if you guys
are gonna come for me let's at least
play some fun games
I mean korilla has been playing some
some crazy interesting positions
Arenberg as well and these are examples
of guys who who have taken some losses
but can easily easily rebound it's just
like live by the sword die by the sword
type of strategy right
yeah differs for everybody I'm on there
it looks like they're repeating over in
group B's Alexander me Stubb versus by
Jin Xin let's take a glance at that we
might be seeing the end of this get yep
the game has just ended and it is a draw
that's surprising yeah I'm surprised by
that I I I don't necessarily did I miss
something
I mean miss is a is a strong word
because I don't think it's like there
was a there was something sitting there
that he just didn't didn't see but
rather I think that the position is just
good for for black I would be confident
here playing this on but the other way
to look at it is that s by G&G I mean he
was making some of the most comfortable
draws of your life I mean the these he's
never in danger and he's saying alright
you know that's another day's work right
there I'm playing with the black pieces
against you know super strong
Grandmaster the second seed in the
tournament the B troop and and he walks
away very unscathed so he may be looking
at it from a tournament perspective at
this point been just securing that draw
putting on one step closer to to just
converting the determinant victory
overall but I can't say that objectively
I agree too much with it
White's putting all his pawns on light
squares and he's he's having that Queen
defend all the weak points right C for a
to g2 and everything else is protected
anything okay like your turn what do you
do
so that's White's defensive idea and no
doubt white he's very solid here and I
don't mean
black is winning or anything but I do
feel like like black is clearly better
here and maybe in a different tournament
situation on a different day maybe a
different opponent might see black play
on so I'm a little bit surprised with
the result but you really can't you know
you know delve into the mind of a guy
who's clearly in first place in the
tournament too much because he probably
has his own reasons do you take anything
away from bhaijan Chi like oh he's not
fighting hard enough so to get that
extra half point not at all no no no
chess players gotta get paid gotta get
that gotta get that shmoney been alright
alright well we have four games total
going on it's so far everything's a draw
Sergei Ehrenberg versus he had in Stein
Grim's in USA versus Iceland let's see
if anything has changed in this group be
game right the this one looked like it
was probably going to be decisive is
what I was saying the last time I I
looked at this and sort of developing as
I expected that a pawn is gonna be
dangerous because even if I lose the
pawn remember that's like part of the
danger of the pawn is just being there
just existing and it's gonna force this
Knight
to let's say take and all of a sudden
that Queen is tied to the knight and
that enables all sorts of tactics on the
King side actually because the Queen and
and Knight are actually both tethered to
the Queen side you never know what that
might change tactically way on the other
side of the board we still have this
idea of getting the Queen out but the
way that Stein Grimson is dealing with
this is he's saying okay
listen you can have Queen h5 check you
can have Queen h7 check you know what
I'll sweeten the deal you can have Queen
h8 check but then the kings going to e7
after running away and there's nothing
after that and your queen is just
looking like a fool in the corner
exactly so that's what he's trying to
say but of course the the best part
about this is white doesn't have to go
and do all that he can save those checks
for maybe once he controls this square
so maybe he plays some other moves I
mean a6 looks extremely logical
I believe it's whose turn is it here at
Queen d5 so it's actually white to play
I mean a6 looks like it makes a lot of
sense Bishop ephors is probably a very
good move here as well
maybe some Knight move
to threaten just renew this idea of
queen h5 but to me a six is easily the
first move that I consider just put that
pun out of harm's way keep tickling the
idea of playing a seven and remember a
combination of a six and Bishop b4 may
actually be really deadly as that pawn
sneaks to a7 Bishop controls a eight we
could actually maybe just win some
material tactically pretty soon so I
think Arenberg is actually doing
fantastic in this position I think he's
got a big advantage what do you consider
for Arenberg playing a move like Knight
e4 attacking the g5 pawn would I
consider 94 absolutely because I would
consider a lot of moves that I'm
probably not going to play if the knight
just came from efore that would be my
main argument with with not with not
playing it if 94 I feel like I take that
Square from my queen I feel like I take
it from my bishop and I I think that the
Queen there has a very serious potential
I also think that having the bishop
there has serious potential for the a
pond so for those two reasons
it's not like I would play Queen efore
Bishop e4 maybe right away but I want to
have that square vacant it's sort of a
great pivot point for either the knight
or the bishop or the Queen to use at
some point but it's almost more powerful
than no piece is sitting there then to
have one there and taking the square
away from someone else so I'd like to
move Knight g3 which is sort of a
clearance and he's not threatening
anything but he might be threatening
something later as all these pieces can
jump into these business squares and
potentially do some damage to Black's
position and you never know which one is
going to jump so you always have to be
calculating and ready for all three of
them and Sergei it looks like he just
made another move let's see what it was
he just played Ben Symons move Knight e4
okay so he wants once the pawn right
once the pond that's a thumbs down for
me
then that you want to explain this move
I'd like to take the g5 pawn that's what
I want to play it for can you elaborate
on that so you got two Knights and their
bullying up on the g5 pawn and if I take
a pawn with my knight if the bishop
takes back then I can take it back with
the other night okay proof right okay I
understand
okay so I'm actually receiving less I
actually received another lesson earlier
today when I was doing a kid's class I
learned that double pawns are called
stacked pawns I didn't know that I
didn't know that was a term I've never
heard that either then that's the second
thing you've learned today double pawns
stack pawns and 94 is actually a
brilliant move which was probably miss
evaluated by me so now we have to
understand what does he want to do in 84
as Bensimon head analyst said the g5
pawn is being targeted here I'm still
waiting for you to completely tear me a
new one with this by the way oh I'm only
just getting started well it's hard for
me to elaborate on the move because the
the extent of my knowledge here is
really what you just said there is that
we want to take this pawn to g5 now
that's very clear however in the
previous position let's back up to when
that night was on e fourth how was black
dealing with this pawn being hanging
that Queen on d8 was watching over so
it's definitely an idea and it's not
insane to think that black may play
Queen d8 now what's going to happen
after Queen d8 why does a few new
options compared to the previous
position this Bishop used to be there so
it was controlling 95 now 95 is an
option by wife also rook d1 is an option
hitting that Queen but I think for
example something like this you know
once you put your Queen here you're kind
of out of harm's way
and you are defending that pawn let's
not forget that if you defend that pawn
like this Queen III is another way to
just say I'm taking this pawn no matter
what add an extra piece in there hit
that g5 pawn to me it looks like in this
position there are a lot of winning
moves maybe not winning on the spot but
I think that that White has is kind of
spoiled for choice 94 going after that
pawn maybe not the one I would go for as
bish before did seem strong but you also
have to keep in mind
Ehrenberg is you know he has very good
instincts here and it looks like he's
dressing him he's going with 94 he's
saying well this one looks good to me
I'm probably gonna get upon for it and
he knows that the resulting position is
probably going to be winning how does
black deal with this the first move I
would really give consideration to as
well other than Queen d8 is I mean at
least have to think about what if I go
g4 because g4 is a way to actually get
rid of your pawn altogether
so if g4 happens then Arenberg I think I
think he's got to think about Knight g5
here pawn takes Bishop takes we can take
here but I'm not sure I'm not sure about
this position is this pin is a little
bit annoying and maybe that rook gets
over to g8 so unless this one works with
Queen e3 and getting h6 I always have
King g7 so I'm not a big fan of not a
big fan of this one he's played the move
g4
so I wonder if we're gonna see Knight g5
or H takes g4 it's now white to play I
think 95 is the other one that I was
suggesting if I get to take this bishop
the light squares are gonna be really
really uncomfortable here for for black
Bishop c4 this pawn hanging Queen h5 if
that pawn moves so the idea is if you
take here I've got a queen h5 in the
position I've got the nine takes f6 all
sorts of tactics here I'm sure something
is gonna work for white so g4 has been
played but I imagine that this was very
expected by Arenberg so he's not gonna
be surprised by this move in fact it's
very likely that he has a retort ready
can see him there on the camera ten
minutes for Arenberg under five minutes
for Stein Grimson and he still got eight
moves to make I haven't really seen
Stein Grimson under time pressure I
can't really say you know what whether
he's quite comfortable there or not but
this doesn't look like the position you
want to play very quickly with black I
think it's very very easy to miss
tactics especially around your King with
that a pawn and probably I think it's
just completely winning for white let's
go over back to Group A and may not be
much to look at with the two games left
but Eric Hansen versus iliyan is Nick be
good just to stay on top of these just
to make sure we don't miss any
explosions absolutely what I mean I see
41 seconds that means that tells a story
right there don't even have to look at
the board 41 seconds Hansen is clearly
uncomfortable here so we did actually
see this maneuver Bishop e7 and Bishop
d8 now I mentioned this earlier Ben but
why was I really suggesting it is
because it's so annoying when you're low
on time if you can't simplify the
position if you can't liquidate then I
mean it's it's one of the most
uncomfortable things you're sitting
there wishing that you know oh I would
just just take this pawn for this pawn
you know you get this I get that
position becomes a lot more simple to
play but if your opponent keeps pawns
and pieces on the board it becomes so
difficult to navigate the complications
as their time takes down so this is a
really good move because I thought after
a 5 we would see what happened in the
game b5 he just keeps pieces on the it
just makes it more complicated it's very
difficult to face after a6 utilizing
that pin they're black forces whites Han
it says f4 I mean it would be crazy to
think you can have both your Knights
attack and not do anything so he has to
budge takes takes there's no 93 check
but instead Eric comes up with the move
Knight 83 and in this position alia is
thinking about what to do but he would
love to keep material on the board he
has to be careful this a pawn though for
example let's say the move b4 happens
not only could I play a7 but also the
move Knight c2 and if King c4 hitting
the rook we do have this idea of rook
takes b4 takes Knight takes and if you
grab my knight I will play a7 and get a
brand new Queen which you can't stop
because that bishop is the wrong color
so there are a few options here but
niche Nick is going to look to find the
most complicated option he can where he
probably keeps as many pieces on the
board and we have to remember in an end
game blacks King is so much better
placed than whites
so if these two pawns here get traded
off for one another the King can at
least capture that pawn on g4 and I
think that black is going to be in an
endgame here that
that he can push so ninja Nick with that
huge time advantage and the calculations
here he's probably gonna find something
pretty tricky
however Hansen is he's doing a good job
struggling the the only way that I see
he has chances is he just has to
liquidate we got to see some pawns
starting to disappear maybe even you
know trade the rooks but lose upon and
just somehow hold an endgame where
you've got that night and you're gonna
put all your pawns on light squares and
say okay what can this Bishop do much
like the by ginchy against Alexander
mystogan so maybe that's an idea to just
sort of bail out at this point Hansen
needs a lifeline because he's got three
to four moves to make before time
control and we need to see some
liquidation otherwise Nisshin ink is
probably going to clean this point and
speaking of claiming points over in
Group B we got to take a look at Dennis
CAD rich versus christen korilla it
looks like korilla has just made a
severe miscalculation and catherine top
of it it looked like a queen it takes b3
hey I get a free pawn because the the C
pawn is pinned but there's a hole in
kirill --is game and i might lead to a
mate look at that
queen f8 played six right it's actually
funny we we had the montreal chest
drawers played a protest league match
and one of our opponents we won the
match maybe because of this but one of
our opponents missed that that the move
Queen h6 was possible and it's actually
a very visual oversight it's quite
possible to miss this I be honest with
you Ben I didn't actually notice Queen
86 was a threat I had to look at it for
quite a while over here was like when we
jump to the position I thought that that
white was trying to bring the rook down
but of course we're getting mated there
the Queen is also doing a good job
defending that pawn all the way from b3
so I actually look at position it's like
I don't even see what's going on but
you'll often see there's like that one
blind spot even for a grandmaster you
know strong as korilla we've seen
crazier blind spots by even like the
world champion and everyone has that you
know made in one that they just don't
see or something here Queen h6 is kind
of that move that's a check followed by
mate on d8 and it comes with checks so
it means that I can't play
like Queen here that would keep an eye
on my pawn it keeps an eye on checkmate
here it even threatens checkmate in one
but it's no good against just Queen h6
and made on the board with check so I
think in this position the problem is
that Queen h6 can't be stopped so what
you have to get ready for after King g8
you need to stop that move and how do
you stop that move that's the issue so
if we look at moves that deal with rook
d8 I mean these moves are out of the
question Queen b6 comes to mind but then
you've got another hole in your position
was that which is this pawn and your
Queen had to be defending that so
there's just it doesn't appear that
there's any way to defend all the weak
points in the position if I play Queen
b6 something like Queen takes f7 here
there's no checkmate here but I will be
able to go to go Queen e8 and rook g7
mate so then I think is just just force
me I think this is just force mate on
the board the worst part for korilla he
doesn't even have move 42 think about
this this just looks like a massive
oversight and I wouldn't be surprised if
he quotes the Queen h6 square as just I
didn't see it I wouldn't be surprised
and you know might look like a horrible
one move blender and to be fair it is
but honestly I think that just counts as
a blind spot for for the Grand Master
here you know I encountered the blind
spot myself oh yeah I'm not a Grand
Master or anything but I was like well
there's no problem Queen goes up to d8
and hey f6 is covered by the rook right
you can't checkmate from the outside in
but it's almost like from the inside out
ya know this is this is weird it all
comes with checks so I think we will
actually see I mean korilla is there and
he is he is just really hating himself
right now he's in his own head he knows
he just missed this idea Queen h6 and
all that was forced so as soon as he
took that pawn on b3 and went into this
line he was sort of pot committed all in
I mean he just has to see how it plays
out and then in the end you find you
miss one move
you're not gonna recover from that
because there's checkmate being
threatened and with less than three
minutes I think he knows he's going down
here there's just no way out there's no
way to cover this and d8 with the one
Queen and the rook
has to
pinning upon so just nothing works for
for black here so he may he may throw in
the towel very soon and it looks like
Dennis CAD rich is going to get another
point on the board very nice
if we go back for just a moment the the
queen taking b3 was Christian's position
looking like before this mistake well I
think it's important also to maybe go
back to this Bishop takes Bishop because
he was probably planning that move as a
result of this whole calculation so it's
unclear whether he would have gone for
that if he had seen this now that being
said Dennis did exactly what I was
saying which is get the King off the the
beef I'll bring that rook over and then
I didn't really calculate but I knew
that there were gonna be something here
the king is wide open for black and you
do have back rank issues and that Bishop
is being kicked away rook takes c4 it's
just a threat and it's not very easy for
me to move my bishop I go here I mean
it's just crazy to leave this this pawn
attack that bishops good what am i doing
down here
so I'm not gonna try to avoid the trade
that much and Bishop takes b3 maybe had
to be played and in this position you're
not doing that well you've still got the
area King position but at least you can
continue fighting with a move like rook
ca for example just cover that back rank
but believe me this is not comfortable
and gorillas probably not that he went
for Queen b3 cuz he thought he was lost
here but he saw Queen b3 as a as a way
to at least grab a pawn and I just
overlooked this line and unfortunately
now it's just completely lost but that
being said I think catcher is still a
huge favor to have won this position if
they had had gotten in maybe we can get
a closer look at the actual players in
the hall with this game CAD rich versus
gorilla yeah that's just despair right
there
yeah no unfortunately there's there's
nothing to do Luke takes C to plate and
not confidently then not confidently
rook takes c2 and this is where you
throw a few checks but like it's pretty
clear he knows that there as you can see
by the look on his face that that
there's no perpetual here
there's no perpetual and kadra she's
just gonna have to spend a little bit of
time figuring out exactly where to put
that King and you know block the right
check and once he figures that out we
will see Kira throwing the towel he had
to sack an entire rook there to even
keep playing a few more moves because me
it was unstoppable so sorry firm to even
look at the board anymore he's just kind
of like I'm at your mercy
no I ready to resign exactly I I don't
want to look at it either it's just like
watching watching your soldier go down
ya know this is that's a tough tough
miss Queen age six but I'll be honest I
actually missed it when we switched to
the game as well so I'm back would also
lose in the same way I think it's one of
those things I saw the big meter turn
those two white and I was and I was
trying to figure out why and it's really
kind of a pretty combination there yeah
but we're looking at the four dentist
CAD rich while we were talking about
this we had a result in group a Liam Lee
and Ray Robson did end up trying their
game they must be expected and so now
there's only one game left in the a
field Hansen versus News Nick and we
have two games left in the B field right
yeah with that draw it looks like
Hansen's game which by the way he did
make some progress in in that game so at
least he's he's still fighting is is
Erik Hansen in the a group he's the last
game still ongoing in that group in the
B group I think we also have the game of
Arenberg and Stein Grimson to look at
because that one really does feel like
like it's gonna end really soon yeah
let's look at that so we have this move
rookie three and I mean I just feel like
checkmates around the corner here Ben we
can show how we got here and it was that
moving Knight g5 that was played and it
seems almost crazy to play this move G
takes h3 is it opens up the Queen
exactly as we had indicated Queen age
five and all sorts of moves here this is
just where you draw a bunch of arrows
and you know that one of those
variations is going to win there are so
many moves to consider here and at the
end of everything we've always got that
a pond so really good position for
Arenberg but he is tanking on time
trying to solve it so this is the only
way that Stan Johnson can come back in
this game is you know having one of
those positions where it looks like me
it's almost me but is it me 97 was
played with the idea I'm gonna put that
night on g6 and I mean I get the feeling
it's just over but you have to find it
right yet you have to prove it there's
gonna be a rook g3 and then there's
gonna be a knight sac is what it looks
like this Knight can almost give it a
self up anywhere let's say here here
just to let the bishop in right just to
let that Bishop hit the knight and let's
say the Queen takes trying to determine
what the best way to capture this is but
probably what the bishop is is good
enough and he's thinking about it was
like rook a jade here he's thinking
about all the crazy moves because if you
take you are just checkmated and he also
has to decide does he even take this
Knight maybe there's other moves in this
position like rook g8 or King f8 so yeah
Arenberg
is tanky on the clock but this might be
a good game to stay with just for the
next couple moves as there's three more
moves until time control and it seems
like this is all or nothing for Arenberg
he's using all his time yeah actually
I'm looking at the time control
situations okay yeah both of the beep
games have not made time control so you
right might as well stick here yep no I
Carola is going to lose that position
and it looks like the do you think that
game will end before this one probably
yeah
yeah I I think so I think so but
honestly the only reason it might not is
because they I mean CAD ROG has got to
figure out exactly where to put his King
and he's winning so there's no point
rushing so honestly in his position I
would take my time make sure to put that
king of the right square whereas this
one we could actually see a checkmate
the next couple moves it depends if he's
sort of figured things out so let's take
a look it was rook g3 check as you can
see on the on the board there and you've
do you have to play yeah you kind of
have to play 96 right yeah you have to
win 86 and he's played it pretty quickly
and he's just put the pressure back on
surrogate right it's just when you when
you have the position that Stangerson
has you just say show me show me the
mate because
there's not much you can do so me as
well plays fast as you can he's already
looking over that score she getting a
little nervous with two moves to play
before time control the nice thing is
it's only two moves the the bad part is
that one of those moves probably has to
be a night sack right because you're
you're in that moment where the the best
movie is probably giving away that night
somewhere and going for going forward
something takes on g6 yes and he's
played and Knight takes f6 this was the
other way to sacrifice a piece a knight
takes f6 and I'm pretty sure that he's
going to capture this yep and I believe
that the move he's going to play here as
Queen the g5 if I'm not mistaken I think
what he wanted to go for was Queen g5
King g7 and then Bishop takes I think
that's what he wants to play because
this you're not even down a piece in
this line because you know if he takes
it that's force meeting - and if he
plays anything else you can reassure
yourself okay you know I'm up I'm not
down material right so you're not
worried that oh I miscalculated or I
might be losing at the end of this so
this is a nice clean variation that I
think Arenberg is it's gonna have to
play that that one last move before time
control as we are on move 40 and he has
just played Queen g5 check I think
that's very good move he's hit time
control he's got nothing to worry about
and I believe this is a I think this is
sound King g7 Bishop takes g6 and I
think white is completely winning
however we've hit time control so again
I don't think this game is gonna finish
right away as he gets up from the board
but Stein Grimson is looking at a dead
lost position and either checkmate or
over massive material loss you think
he'll give it a look over here
Stein grimaces oh yeah yeah no question
no question you definitely check this
one out because for example there's a
move like King f8 in this position right
if I play King f8 here you got to give
real consideration of this because
technically you know you're not down
material if I even count the pawns
they're dead events oh no King f8 looks
like the most reasonable move on the
board unless it's completely losing to
something but this looks like a good
good catch
from Arenberg why should B be better
here although I have to say King FA is
quite a resilient move because if I take
this we can take back and I don't see a
checkmate but what I think is that in a
position like this there will be a
checkmate it doesn't have to be right
away but with the placement of all the
pieces and don't forget this a pawn
there's no question this is winning but
if I was black I think King f8 probably
the best way to play one can we glanced
back at can't reach his game against
korilla see if gorilla is still putting
in those checks it looks like it yep
he's still putting in the checks they're
approaching move 40 the move rook b2 has
just been played and I believe you
realize sort of deciding here the thing
is Queen
it's a d1 check King a2 Queen a4 is kind
of a known perpetual idea but we've got
that Queen don't forget about it on f8
that plans to come back to a3 so for
example something like this if you check
one more time that's it for you and this
should be this should be completely
winning and that's why korilla doesn't
go for that check instead he plays Queen
d3 so I think we'll see maybe King maybe
King a 1 is an idea ok probably doesn't
matter but King a one actually it looks
like the best move if Queen check here
I'm maybe not gonna go up because of
that I'll play rook here you're out of
checks now and if Queen wants to go
there again
don't forget that Queen from f8 still
guarding that square that's what you
play when you're playing someone online
you play Queen a3 check they play King
be 1 and then you take their Queen you
have to throw that that last minute
trying but fortunately if you have that
Auto move on yes exactly the over the
board is not going to work but the other
thing is that after King a1 if Queen d1
King a2 we actually transposed the Queen
d1 check
so they've hit move 40 here but I don't
actually imagine we're gonna see
gorillas play on too much check Queen a3
has been played this is on the board
Queen takes e4 I believe he just played
and completely winning for white but
down a full Rockies gorilla the reason
you play on here is as soon as white
wants to get that rook into the action
well it's just not going to work because
then there's checks you have to deal
with so probably has to be a little bit
accurate here just make sure you find
find all those moves
maybe rook b8 is is the consideration
block the next check with the Queen and
try to get your queen on the b2 square
to threaten to mate and try to force an
exchange of Queens but again completely
winning position the cache will just
take a little bit time here and sort
this one out but unfortunately for
gorilla making time control doesn't
really help them out here right well
we're waiting for moves to come in for
the group B games in Group A Eric Hanson
is playing Illya Nick and actually the
chat on YouTube is talking about Eric
Hanson yeah
MGR League infidel says Hanson is always
finishing last in these but Nicholas
Hansen's and I wonder if there's
relation there sets him straight Hansen
is three and a half out of six before
this round that's pretty good
remember he's the last seated person in
the field yep he is the lowest rated
seed coming into this tournament and
he's already upset
laQuan the number one seed so he's he's
lost to tari you know what i mean so you
can beat and loosed it to anyone in this
in this tournament Tori's rated just one
point higher than him at the bottom of
the the table in terms of the initial
seeding and look Long's right at the top
so I think the players know that
everyone's pretty strong in this field
and Hansen by the way made some serious
strides in his game first of all he made
time control very big deal
second of all he traded off a knight and
Bishop another big deal because you get
to that rook endgame you have better
chances to draw and I actually like what
I just saw the last move there looked
like g4 was played to get that King up
to gh Nick let's take a look at that
let's get that board up there King up to
g3 and I mean he's he's he's doing
pretty well here I think there's very
very good chances to actually hold this
position you get that King there you
always have maybe like a d5 check to
chase the King back and that pawn f3 is
probably gonna fall you also have rope
down here and checked there and take
that pawn so still a bit tricky
obviously black is slightly better but
now that we're gonna Brooke in
and things have really been liquidated I
wasn't speaking about that for like the
whole broadcast is that why just has to
liquidate the queenside ponds and he did
exactly that he traded the a pond in the
B pond and I think that was the the key
to better drawing chances so I think
he's I think he's comfortable he's
comfortable here all right let's go back
to group B and keep an eye on CAD rich
against korilla rook just moved to f2
putting pressure on that f7 pawn right
the move was rook f2 he's got the checks
covered right here and checks from this
diagonal he's gonna pair it with the
Queen so that's the idea rook or sorry
King to g8 has just been played and now
CAD rich has to find probably a series a
few a few accurate moves but maybe it's
more than fourteen capable of that the
question is more just preference how you
want to do it here Queen b3 looks
reasonable hit that pawn the queen is
going to go back to e7 yeah he plays
Queen b3 and I think black has got to
play Queen c7 here that's on the board
Queen e7 yeah yeah and after Queen e7
again now you've sort of chased the
Queen back you've covered the important
checking diagonals and ranks so the king
is actually safe here and now you need
this rook to do something else now the
Rope needs to be rerouted so if the rope
can ever get down there for a check and
then you use sort the Queen out it's
that h8 square that's gonna be where all
the the checkmate action takes place so
I think he's gonna try to get that rope
in behind in the position here and that
should lead to a yeah I check me or
resignation more likely are you
surprised that korilla is playing on uh
no I'm not surprised because white
doesn't have any pawns that can move so
he's actually just gonna sit here and
say well I have the idea if you ever
bring your rook down to do this stuff
your King is exposed and I'm going to
check you and you only have one Queen so
you shouldn't be able to block
everything at least that's blacks
thought process that's why you keep
playing
I don't think this is disrespectful
anything like that I would actually
probably play it on to because from for
blacks perspective you're saying that if
you bring all your pieces in maybe I
check you and if you don't you can't
break through right like at some point
you have to bring the rope down because
this is the only weak point you defend
it twice you know what else can white do
he's gotta bring the rook in he doesn't
have any pawns no bayonets nothing so
it's you just force him to find a few
moves and as soon as korilla sees that
there's no checks or that he's getting
the rook in believe me he's gonna resign
on the spot but you may as well make him
show it Dennis played Queen c4 is this a
waiting move I mean to c4 right Queen c4
well I mean he he was also threatening
with the Queen there maybe to just play
rook here and gain time hitting the
Queen on maybe your way to the e8 square
so he has this small idea but also it's
the Queen is sort of centralizing
herself getting a little closer to the
center watching a lot of important
squares like a four give me the King
some breathing room so he's just
repositioning before before the final
strike here Queen d7 korilla doesn't
have to think about too much it's just
whether or not Dennis finds the
continuation the continuing moves well
for my sake I hope that one of these
games and soon so we can talk to white
players it would be nice it looks like
as we have actually haven't had CAD ROG
on the right on the show the interesting
to get him down here and you know
korilla to our longtime viewers is no
stranger to these kinds of broadcasts
usually sitting in this room or in the
other one and he might just be working
I'm not really sure he might be working
the US Championship coming up right in
just 12 days yes just christmas is here
twelve days away on Wednesday March 20th
the US Championship kicks off its a
twelve player round-robin there's also
gonna have the US women's field as well
the Women's Championship and we know
that Sam Shanklin is going to be there
defending his US title against the
strongest national championship in the
entire world
we were talking about Wes
so Fabiano kara wanna the the recent
world championship challenger Hikaru
Nakamura in the world Leonard the migas
what a fab eat challenge not Hikaru oh
did I did I switch the order maybe you
were talking about the prestigious
chess960 World Championship I went to
London I saw I know I know it was Fabien
card and Caro has been streaming a lot
more yeah no time for such things you
know hey Caro is world number two in the
universal ratings yes the URS yes okay
so that's gonna be at u.s. chess champs
calm just like this is so there I got my
paw again
oh absolutely no like if you want to
visit st. Louis like this is the
absolute time to do it
I think Nazi Pike is a is not defending
shield title I'm not sure why yeah but
she is not in the field this year for
the US women's but Sam is yes it's gonna
be there and I think people are gonna be
really excited just to see what Sam can
do in terms of like a repeat performance
because that was a breakout performance
probably people maintain the same
skepticism like oh he can't do it again
but it's what people thought the first
time so wondering how he's gonna how
he's going to play even sort of walking
in as as overlooked anymore of people
people know that Sam is is a big deal
since he won the US title as well he's
gained a ton of rating and he's been
winning classical tournaments so the guy
is real real scared right now he's on
the career high yeah he's breaking
through to to the elite yeah you know so
let's take a look at our our comments
here
Joshua post Emma says the Universal
rating system is almost as legitimate as
chess cube ratings hey now buddy you
better mean that chest cube ratings are
really legit right yeah but both are
equally valid yeah and but actually
there's a big discrepancy because
Nakamura is a really big blitz player
right he's really great but as far as
classical he's dropping his feet a
classical he's number 16 in the world
that's right yeah he's he is falling out
the let's say the top 10 which is you
know big news for for an act like that
doesn't happen you almost think if knack
is just a permanent top 10 resident but
that's not the case nowadays as I mean
he still maintains his incredible form
in blitz and rapid over the board and
and online but I think he will be
playing some a lot more blitz and rapid
tournaments this year including the
grand chess to her and stuff like that
so I mean Hikaru is he's got to make
that resurgence so are we gonna see him
into the top 10 again or we're gonna see
him maybe out of the Union top 20 like
players around him are are gaining I
mean there's some scary people in the
top 50 in the world right now but I
think we all know that once you're in
that 2750 Club the rating can go up and
down and it really does fluctuate a lot
and just because you see who car out of
the top 10 it's not like his you know
career is at an all-time low I think he
can easily bounce back and maybe the US
Championship is a perfect way to do that
with a big performance yeah it really is
I'm glad you brought up the grand chest
or because it starts in May and it goes
until December there's more events now
than ever before like this is a really
crowded calendar and Hikaru I'm
interested to see if he can defend his
grand chest toward championship you know
you have to win the knock out the final
four in London at the end of the year as
well and that he really proved that he
belonged and he is the defending grand
chest Tour champion okay so how about
Ehrenburg Stein Grimson have we has
there been made any progress by Aaron
Burke
no well it's his move I mean Stein grips
and played the move that I recommended
King f8 I think that it wasn't very
difficult to recommend it it's just the
only move King f8 simply had to be
played and I count out black in his
position yet I think this is actually
reasonably tricky like for a position
that I would consider totally winning
for white and I still do consider it
that way this is probably one of the
trickiest because the material is
actually dead even and you actually got
a bishop that's hanging right I could
take that next turn so in some ways this
is like one of the weirdest completely
winning positions I've ever
scene because it should be just over it
feels like for white but King f8 is
surprisingly resilient and at the very
least it's gonna force Arenberg here to
make some may be accurate moves like
sometimes when you're completely winning
you don't need to be accurate there's
many winning lines you can pick and
choose here it looks like I'm actually
surprised that maybe how much patience
is required to play white here I didn't
realize it would be this tricky but King
f8 I think is very resilient and stein
Grimson probably looks at this position
and doesn't think he's out of it yet I
don't think he's he's lost hope a few
accurate moves you might throw in the
towel out okay this is why but he's got
to find them here and they're not
immediately obvious to me well I hate
asking for inaccurate play but is there
a situation here where you could
feasibly see Ehrenburg slipping up and
losing the victory yes I mean there's
lots of ways to to slip up here first of
all you've got this bishop hanging
blacks gonna take here if there's ever a
check then the King seems to run to e7
so it's not that I see a particular
continuation that may achieve that but I
just think that if white doesn't play
very accurately blacks position is very
very obvious that if you get checked you
move if not maybe I try to take this
pawn maybe I just take on g2 maybe black
is just completely lost in all these
lines but I don't see the immediate kill
here and it's kind of like like this has
to be something a bishop move here a
queen here and a rook there that's a
checkmate but we have to achieve that
and he sort of has to arrange the pieces
correctly Bishop h7 in order to play
Queen here and threatened rook down
there maybe I maybe I have like Queen
Queen d8 so I think he just has to play
like one or two very good moves and okay
in this position for example this is
like totally winning right because
you're just taking pawns the king is
right in the middle of the board that
there's no worries there but I think I
think you really feel like you're in
with a fighting chance considering
earlier there was like looked like
almost forced made on the board and and
he survived to here so I
think that maybe Bishop h7 is actually
that very accurate move we're looking
for in this position but that's not
immediately obvious to me so like
Ehrenburg is really double-checking
things here and and he knows that this
is not just completely over even though
maybe the evaluation certainly suggests
it I'm sure
okay and Dennis CAD rich and Christine
Carrillo looks a little bit different I
think the same result though is
happening okay so CAD rich put his rook
on f4 guarding the pond so basically
here everything's protected right he's
achieved a position where everything's
protected and then what he decided to do
was once he did that he said okay time
to take this pond get that off the board
I'm not sure if this is like the best or
worse I who knows but his idea and again
this is an example of position which is
totally Winnie but you don't need to be
accurate you're up a rope right there's
probably like ways the computer is
saying oh no you have to go here but I
mean your upper broke many ways to win
this position I like his simple approach
which is hey I'm gonna go take this
everything's protected and you can't
protect this pawn forever so I'm gonna
take it
and then I have the idea to run my king
over here where it's much safer and it
actually does have some palm cover and
then from there I should be able to
achieve a position where I get my rope
down there at least that's probably his
thought process so I think what we see
is exactly that on the board as we bring
up the current position and that King
has gone for a stroll went on a journey
took the scenic route and king efore has
just been played Queen e7 probably King
f3
once you tuck that king in there or or
over here then I think we'll see him get
that rook into the action so once we see
that I think the sort of winning idea is
gonna be a lot more apparent but yeah
this is the current position you took
that pawn off the board and I just needs
to get that rope down to the last rank
but again I think it's very fair to play
this on as black because there's always
going to be checks to to considered so
this is a completely winning definitely
not tricky but you know can't be played
instantly it's not not one of those
trivial wins you do have to think how do
I get my rook down there and not give up
a perpetual
well it looks like we are not gonna be
able to talk to any of these players
unfortunately at this juncture but let's
look at Eric Hanson's game for the last
time hey the last game in Group A
handsome music this was the position
last time we saw kini 4 and I was saying
definitely expect King g3 and that's
what we've got
d5 rook a for Brooke f6 I wouldn't be
surprised to see the rook just shuffle
here I wonder what Eric is thinking
about maybe he suspects - maybe another
way to draw
I shouldn't say another way to draw as
if as if this is some sort of forced
draw or anything
I mean ilya is still pushing here
because if you lose this pawn and then
black takes this pawn it's not over a
king and pawn and game is losing their
rook endgame can be tricky especially
with this pass pawn so I don't think
this is Triple E at all but again I
think Eric has made considerable strides
since the presence of Bishop and knight
on the board and stuff like that so I
think Eric could be happy with this rook
before seems to be the main candidate
move in this position as the last two
moves were just seem to be waiting moves
okay for Brooke f6 so Brooke b4 seems
logical I just wonder what Ilya is is
planning he may be planning something
like rook here I don't know I'm not sure
rook here trying to say you can't just
wait forever and then if the rook goes
down then we may have some weird
position where everyone's taking pawns
but it's hard to say for the moment the
other thing you might want to do is play
h6 and that actually looks more and more
likely that he wanted to bring his rook
here so that there wouldn't be a move
like rook b6 hitting those two pawns so
maybe he wants to play chess X push the
pawn up the board maybe maybe exchange a
bit and try to take this pawn on d4 and
trade it for the pawn on f3 so still
still some chances for an Asian akin the
same game
and Eric's also getting a little low on
time right nunik is able to play pretty
quickly in this endgame because he's
he's got nothing to lose he's the one
playing for the win and I the more I
look at this I have to say I do probably
expect a draw but it's kind of hard for
hard for me to say because some of these
rook end games it's just not not in a
book right it's just you have that
feeling a lot of them are drawn for
example he's just played them of h5 and
I get the feeling this is this is more
and more draws but he has some ideas for
example take stakes what does he want to
do if he could would be to put this rook
here where it actually defends every
single punt kind of weird but maybe this
is maybe this is an idea or at least
it's the ideas going for and if white
plays g5 then there's two things there's
you know the rook being on this file and
then there's the rook being on this rank
here so maybe rookie six and try to stay
protecting this pawn White has sometimes
an idea like rook here and wrote there
but yeah the more I look at this I do
think that it's probably probably drawn
but not an easy one Eric will definitely
have to work here and as I mentioned his
clock is getting a little bit low so you
know long term he has to make sure that
he doesn't get a long time again because
there's no more time right yeah 30 extra
minutes I already hit that 40th move
we're gonna wrap up the show here from
st. Louis but let's take a look at our
standings so far in Group A it's looking
to be a repeat of two days ago all draws
with Jeffrey Zhong is still at the top
do you think what do you think John's
chances are of staying in its position
over the next few days
well obviously he's got the best chances
personally because he's I mean you want
to be situated right at that top
position going into those final days in
any tournament but the thing about this
tournament is it's not it's not a Swiss
so it's not like being in the in the top
position you know you play the guy in
second place it's not the case you may
play the guy in last place in fact I
think you may still have to play
everything so it's not so much about
that that the pairing system is already
determined so he knows who he has to
play and it's gonna be no easy no easy
games from here on out
Hanson initially if they draw will both
join at four points in second place and
you can just see how tight the
tournament is you
the tied for fourth position right now
goes all the way down into the bottom
half of this table and you could have
basically one point separating first
place and like sixth place so this is a
very tight tournament the players are
going to be drawing a lot in in you know
when you have these high ratings when we
head-to-head and that one point gap is
is not completely safe and I think at
this point honestly nearly anyone with
three and a half points good could still
win the tournament yeah and the final
day on Sunday could be really exciting
when it drives to the playoff system
because we will have a playoff if there
is a tie for first place right let's
look at our standings in Group B and I
understand actually these are assuming
there you see some asterisks there
assuming that the results we think will
happen by ginchy still with the lead and
he has played all of his closest
competition already bars Pulitzer oak
and mystic Adana as he played CAD rich I
think he has in theodoro yes so in
theory in theory smooth sailing for a
year for by ginchy in the last two days
right but he's gonna be playing some
unpredictable players right this what I
was mentioning about Arenberg and
korilla is these guys play some really
fun attacking chess and who knows if
that's like the the weakness that we
haven't seen yet if that might expose
something it'd be a different game I
think we also mentioned what happens
when guys aren't fighting for first
place well it's got to play three guys
that are gonna try to play spoiler Ben's
so we'll see how that goes for him but
yes you're also playing people who
aren't doing as well aren't as inform in
this tournament so you do naturally feel
like he should have better chances there
but you know things sort of unchanged at
the top of the table here in Group B a
lot of draws by Jin she maintains his
lead it's definitely a more securely
than the one that Jeffery has in the a
group as there's a little bit more gap
between the players there but I think
it's still reasonable to assume that
with a win
if CAD rich pulls this off as he should
jumps up to three and a half he can
still score some big results with three
games to play and you know all these
players gonna be fighting for some prize
money and the guys near the top are
going to look to
catch by ginchy all right and we hope
that you here to join us over the next
two days this weekend we're gonna wrap
up the third annual spring chess classic
and tomorrow actually we're gonna have a
special guest host and we're not
replacing you we're just replacing me
don't worry it's actually you probably
really enjoy because it's Caleb Denby
where he's gonna bring a little bit of
road to 2002 the spring chess classic
he'll be hosting our penultimate round
8:00 tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. Central Time
and remember the games kickoff at 1:00
p.m. Central time at us chess champs
calm so you can be with us the whole
time if you want to thanks for joining
us in the chat today we had a really
good time our streamer was Tammy Hyde
and the world's greatest production B
team of course as always Dani Machuca
was your technical director Isaac's
trance graphics and audio my name is Ben
Simon he is Grandmaster I'm on Hamilton
come on it's gonna be a fun weekend
oh it sure will I can't wait to see with
all these players tied near the top of
the table what's gonna happen and really
who wins these tournaments and until
tomorrow we say so long from the
show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you